er galt als einer der
vielversprechendsten kandidaten für
außerirdisches leben
der exoplanet proxima centauri doch
selbst wenn es dort leben gegeben haben
sollte am 24 märz 2017 wurde es nach
neuesten erkenntnissen spätestens
vernichtet was ist passiert und was
bedeutet das für die alien suche jetzt
den klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
das ist wirklich ein herber rückschlag
es sieht schlecht aus für leben auf dem
exoplaneten proxima centauri bis dato
galt er als ein vielversprechender
kandidat für leben in der nähe unseres
sonnensystems proxima centauri ist ein
stern nur 4,2 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt und sein exoplaneten also
proxima centauri b kreis in der
habitablen zone um den stern also da wo
wasser nicht verdampft und auch nicht
gefriert also leben möglich ist zudem
ist er fast so groß wie die erde also
nahezu perfekte bedingungen und wenn
nach denen sich immer weiter
verdichteten erkenntnissen gehen das
nahezu überall leben entsteht wo die
bedingungen dafür da sind dann wäre
außerirdisches leben dort nahezu
zwingend gewesen aber damit ist es nun
aus und vorbei hätte es dort leben
gegeben spätestens vor knapp einem jahr
+ 42 lichtjahre wäre es vernichtet
worden
das ergeben jüngste daten analysen ein
forschungsteam um die astronomen mary
des mcgregor von der carnegie
institution for science hat das
sternensystem mit dem atacama large
millimeter submillimeter array kurz alma
in chile untersucht und in den daten
jetzt ein katastrophales ereignis
entdeckt merediths mcgregor der 24 märz
2017 war kein normaler tag für proxima
centauri ja an diesem tag passierte eine
absolute katastrophe
die temperatur und das muss man sich mal
vorstellen stieg für zehn sekunden um
achtung das tausendfache an maximal war
diese eruption auf dem stern sogar zehn
mal heißer als die stärksten ausbrüche
auf der erde
zitat der flyer erzeugt strahlung im
gesamten bereich des elektromagnetischen
spektrums so das forschungsteam und
dabei ist proxima centauri nur ein roter
zwerg der exoplaneten b kreis also viel
dichter um ihn als die erde um die sonne
um sich in der habitablen zone wie hier
in unserem system zu befinden dieser
flair hat den exoplaneten voll erwischt
und falls es dort leben gegeben haben
sollte ist es spätestens durch diese
eruption vernichtet worden aber
wahrscheinlich war es nicht der erste
ausbruch meint das forschungsteam zitat
in den milliarden jahren seit proxima
centauri de entstanden es könnten
strahlen ausbrüche wie dieser die
atmosphäre und mögliche ozeane verdampft
und die oberfläche des planeten
sterilisiert haben so merkel
mcgregor es ist wirklich zum mäuse
melken da findet man mal einen
vielversprechenden kandidaten für
außerirdisches leben und dann gibt es
irgendein detail das leben doch
unmöglich macht bedeutet dass jetzt das
es immer so ist also vielleicht doch die
these stimmt dass wir einzigartig im
universum sind weil es eben doch immer
wieder irgendeinen haken gibt
wahrscheinlich ja wahrscheinlich ist es
nicht so es gibt so viele sternsysteme
in jeder galaxie milliarden und es gibt
so viele galaxien auch milliarden
statistisch ist es nahezu unmöglich dass
es kein leben außerhalb der erde gibt
wir müssen vielleicht nur etwas länger
suchen und die erkenntnisse der exo
biologen sprechen ja auch dafür das
leben relativ schnell entsteht es ist
quasi nur eine weiterentwicklung aus
molekülen und der zwingende weg bei
jedem komplexer werdenden system und das
passiert wohl auch schneller als gedacht
ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema
außerirdische und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer bei whatsapp dann erfahrt
ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion
folglich zum mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier
passiert der direkte draht zu mir
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken außerirdisches leben leben
entsteht viel früher als angenommen
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran